finally able to sit side by side not
going to lie feels a big big relief like
somebody touched my heart with a palm
like this
huddled close together on a porch swing
here finally i can say that i'm safe
these are but two of more than 3 million
ukrainian refugee stories
tamila kovolchuk didn't want to leave
ukraine but after airports a hospital
and school were bombed around her her
children told her she needed to get out
after an excruciating eight-day journey
to get to her son's home in calgary
tamila still can't help but think of
home and her other son she had to leave
behind
this is the second time arena pustovic
and her daughter polina have been forced
to flee fighting first leaving their
home near donbass to live in key back in
2014 now calling canada home at least
for now
scenes of tearful embraces are unfolding
all across canada and soon there may be
many more a federal emergency travel
program is about to open canada's doors
wide most visa requirements will be
waived for ukrainians to stay at least
two years canadian organizations working
to welcome fleeing ukrainians say they
don't know how many are coming but
they're bracing for thousands and they
say they're ready to help make the
transition as smooth as possible
unfortunately in war nothing is seamless
and it's really devastating and it's
really difficult but
hopefully together as a community we can
at least make it a little bit less
stressful
those already here are finding comfort
in daly calls home i wanted somebody
like i wanted them to come here to see
them
and i don't know to hug them holding out
hope that day comes soon lauren pulling
global news calgary